[Musique]
Saint-Quentin en Eveline accueille le
tout premier concept de coiving
d'Île-de-France baptisé le Premium ce
projet devrait regrouper deux immeubles
hybrides mélant coiving et coworking né
dans les années 2000 et tout droit venu
des États-Unis cette nouvelle façon de
cohabiter
se développe de plus en plus en France
pour en parler nous sommes avec Philippe
rayer bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur et président d'akera
développement ainsi que promoteur de
l'opération oui est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer qu'est-ce que vont
abriter ces deux bâtiments sur ce site
qui est derrière moiù on va construire
un ensemble de 13000 m² composé ené de
deux unités il y a une opération de
coiving coorking de 10000 m² pour Babel
community qui va regrouper 245 chambres
hôtelières destinées aux jeunes actifs
et un immeuble de 3000 m² de bureaux
indépendants avec des
prestations en rapport avec la situation
c'estàd tout proche de la gare qui sera
destiné donc à un utilisateur unique ou
à des multiutilisateurs et concrètement
en construisant ces deux bâtiments
qu'est-ce que vous proposez comme offre
qu'est-ce qui va y avoir à l'intérieur
c'est un immeuble indépendant de coiving
et de coworking avec un service hôtelier
restauration salle de sport et au
rez-de-chaussé et au dernier étage il y
a des mètres carrés qui sont destinés à
qui sont ouverts à l'extérieur en
coworking donc c'est le concept de de
bureau partagés et ensuite sur le
deuxième immeuble qui qui est collé et
qui est mais qui est indépendant qui va
faire 3000 m Carr qui s'appelle le
Premium enfin l'ensemble c'est le
Premium c'est un petit immeuble de
bureau qui fait 3000 m² sur 8 étages
avec des vues qui sont superbe vu sur la
gare et vu sur le le sud de 50 an000lg
et qui sera destiné à des PME PMI dans
le cadre si possible d'une acquisition
aujourd'hui la toute première pierre du
projet premium a été déposée au cœur de
l'hypercentre de 50 ans en iveline ce
projet il a notamment été mené par the
Babel community donc aujourd'hui je suis
avec Benoît jaobbert vous êtes président
de the Babel community bonjour bonjour
alors est-ce que vous pouvez d'abord
nous expliquer en quoi consiste ce tout
nouveau concept de coliving qui est le
premier à voir le jour en île-de-fance
le concept Babel c'est un concept de
bâtiment hybride qui metène à la fois de
l'hébergement mais également du
coworking
un restaurant une salle de sport
beaucoup d'événements un lieu propice à
la rencontre puisque nos clients se
rencontre au sein d'espace commun
d'espace collectif très nombreux du
sport du restaurant mais également plein
d'espaces communs des jardins partagés
au sein même du même bâtiment et à qui
s'adresse ce concept de coliving alors
il s'adresse à tout le monde mais mais
globalement c'est avant tout une réponse
à la à la difficulté de se loger dans
les grandes métropoles notamment de la
par des jeunes actifs qui sont à la
recherche de deux choses qui sont à la
recherche de logement flexible sans
engagement ils savent pas forcément
combien de temps ils vont avoir besoin
de ce logement faut que ce logement soit
équipé meublé avec des services et puis
il faut que ce soit un logement dans
lequel ils vont pouvoir rencontrer du
monde on l'a vraiment pensé non pas
comme une chambre d'hôtel mais comme un
véritable appartement pour y vivre
plusieurs mois pourir même plusieurs
années et donc c'est le premier civing
d'Île-de- France et pourquoi vous avez
choisi moninil Bretonneux qu'est-ce qui
vous a amené jusqu'ici on a ici eu
l'occasion de rencontrer les équipes
d'akera un promoteur qui a su nous
convaincre sur le dynamisme du de la du
territoire et puis des élus qui nous ont
expliqué à quel point les entreprises
locales avaient des problématiques
d'hébergement et qu'il était très
important d'essayer de l' loger sur
place et non pas ailleurs et c'est assez
rapidement qu'on a été convaincu et
qu'on a convaincu notre partenaire la
Caisse des dépôts qui est aujourd'hui
notre co-investisseur merci beaucoup
merci